>>> NEW DETAILS IN THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THAT FATAL
SHOOTING OF CINEMATOGRAPHER
HALYNA HUTCHINS.
AFTER ALEC BALDWIN WAS TOLD IT
WAS A QUOTE COLD GUN WITH NO
LIVE AMMUNITION BEFORE IT WENT
OFF.
ONE CREW MEMBER AND EYEWITNESS
BLAMED HER DEATH ON NEGLIGENCE
AND UNPROFESSIONALISM, AND
QUESTIONED THE EXPERIENCE OF
HANNAH GUTIERREZ.
HE WROTE QUOTE TO SAVE A DIME
SOMETIMES YOU HIRE PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT FULLY QUALIFIED FOR THE
COMPLICATED AND DANGEROUS JOB,
AND YOU RISK THE LIVES OF OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE CLOSE AND YOUR
LIVES AS WELL.
CNN'S LUCY JOINS US FROM SAN
JOSE.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU HEARING ABOUT
THE PREVIOUS GUN INCIDENTS WE
ARE HEARING ON SETS?
>> CNN HAS LEARNED THAT
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR DAVE HALLS
WAS THE SUBJECT OF COMPLAINTS
OVER SAFETY AS WELL AS BEHAVIOR
ON SET ON TWO DIFFERENT
PRODUCTIONS BACK IN 2019.
SOURCES TELL CNN THAT THESE
COMPLAINTS INCLUDE A DISREGARD
FOR SAFETY WITH GUN SAFETY, AND
PYROTECHNICS, THINGS LIKE HAVING
EXIT LANES, AND FIRE EXITS BEING
CONSISTENTLY BLOCKED AND ALSO
REPORTS OF INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL
BEHAVIOR.
NOW CNN SPOKE TO MAGGIE GOLD, A
PROP MAKER AND A LICENSED PYRO
TECHNICIAN.
SHE TOLD CNN HALLS NEGLECTED TO
HOLD SAFETY MEETINGS AND
ANNOUNCE A WEAPON ON SET.
THE ONLY REASON THE CREW WAS
MADE AWARE IS BECAUSE THE
ASSISTANT'S PROP MANAGER
ACKNOWLEDGED THE SITUATION EACH
DAY.
ACCORDING TO THE AFFIDAVIT, IT
WAS DAVE HALLS WHO PICKED UP THE
WEAPON, HANDING IT TO BALDWIN,
SHOUTING COLD GUN, INDICATING IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SAFE.
THAT WAS PREPARED BY HANNAH
GUTIERREZ, 24 YEARS OLD, THE
DAUGHTER OF LEGENDARY GUN SMITH
FELL REID.
THIS WAS HER SECOND TIME AS
WORKING AS HEAD ARMOUR.
AND SHE DISCUSSED HER RELATIVE
LACK OF EXPERIENCE ON A PODCAST
THAT AIRED IN SEPTEMBER.
>> DAD HAS TAUGHT ME EVERYTHING
BUT A LOT OF THINGS, YOU KNOW, I
KIND OF JUST CAUGHT ON BY
MYSELF, AND EVERYTHING.
JUST OBSERVATION, WATCHING HIM
DO THINGS OR JUST KNOWING HOW
THE FIREARMS WORK.
I THINK LOADING BLANKS WAS THE
SCARIEST THING TO ME, I WAS
LIKE, OH, I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, HE TAUGHT ME
THAT, AND EVENTUALLY BY THE TIME
I WAS LIKE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE A SPECIFIC BLANK GO
WHEN YOU WANT IT TO, RATHER THAN
IT HITTING THE EMPTY CYLINDERS
AND EVERYTHING.
>> SHE TOLD CNN SHE NEARLY
DIDN'T TAKE THAT PREVIOUS FILM
JOB BECAUSE OF HER CONCERNS
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE.
CNN HAS REACHED OUT TO BOTH
HALLS AND GUTIERREZ FOR COMMENT.
NO WORD YET, ALISYN.
>> OKAY.
AND HOW ARE PEOPLE REMEMBERING
TODAY HALYNA.
>> WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THE
FAMILY TODAY.
WE KNOW THAT THE HUSBAND AND HER
SON WERE IN TOWN THIS WEEKEND.
OBVIOUSLY DEVASTATED BY THIS
TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE LOSS.
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM FOLKS
WHO KNEW HER, HER BEST FRIEND,
IN FACT, SPOKE TO CNN HOLDING
BACK TEARS, TALKING ABOUT THE
TRAGEDY THAT HAS BE FALLEN THIS
YOUNG FAMILY.
>> MY HEART JUST BREAKS FOR HER
KID, WHO'S -- HE'S ALMOST LIKE
MY OWN KID.
WE'VE HUNG OUT AND BEEN TOGETHER
FOR YEARS, AND I GUESS IN SOME
LEVEL I WISH I HAD TOLD HALYNA I
WOULD STEP IN IF SHE NEEDED
ANYTHING, BE HIS GOD MOTHER OR
SOMETHING, BUT I DIDN'T EVEN
THINK OF SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
I MEAN, IT WOULDN'T HAVE EVEN
BEEN SOMETHING THAT I EVER COULD
HAVE IMAGINED HONESTLY
HAPPENING.
>> Reporter: A LOT OF GRIEF, AND
SO MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THIS TRAGIC, TRAGIC
MURDER, SHOOTING, I'M SO SORRY,
SHOOTING COULD HAVE TAKEN PLACE.
ALISYN.
>> JUST DEVASTATING TO HEAR FROM
HER FRIEND THERE.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS IS
FORMER NYPD OFFICER TURNED STUNT
COORDINATOR AND ARMOURER, SCOTT
KASHA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
I'VE BEEN LOOKING FORWARD TO
TALKING TO YOU BECAUSE I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THIS
HAPPENED.
WHEN AN ASSISTANT DIRECTOR HANDS
THE STAR A GUN AND SAYS COLD
GUN, DOES THAT MEAN THAT SOMEONE
HAS CHECKED THAT THE GUN IS
EMPTY?
IS THAT NORMALLY HOW IT'S
SUPPOSED TO WORK?
>> SO, ALISYN, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME ON.
A FIRST PERSON SHOULD NEVER BE
TOUCHING A WEAPON.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT SHOULD BE
TOUCHING A WEAPON IS THE
ARMOURER, ANY ASSISTANT, AND
TALENT, GIVEN RIGHT BEFORE THE
TAKE AND TAKEN BACK AFTER THE
TAKE IS DONE.
WHEN I'M ON A SET, ANYTIME I
HAVE A WEAPON, IT'S EITHER IN MY
HOLSTER, IN A CASE OR I'LL TAKE
IT TO THE BATHROOM.
AN AD SHOULD NEVER BE TOUCHING A
GUN.
THEY CAN ASK FOR A SAFETY
INSPECTION, THEY CAN ASK
QUESTIONS, BUT NO CREW MEMBER
OTHER THAN THE ARMOURER OR THE
TALENT SHOULD BE TOUCHING A
WEAPON EVER.
>> ACCORDING TO THE AFFIDAVIT
AND SOME WITNESSES WAS TOUCHING
IT, AND HANDING IT TO ALEC
BALDWIN, AND BY THE WAY, WE ALSO
LEARNED THAT IT WAS ON A CART
OUTSIDE OF THE BUILDING WHERE
THE SCENE WAS BEING SHOT, SO IT
WAS RESTING ON A CART OUTSIDE
THEY SAID BECAUSE OF COVID-19
PROTOCOLS, I GUESS, SO WHAT DOES
THAT TELL YOU, THAT THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR IS AT FAULT
HERE OR THE ARMORER OR WHO?
>> SO, EVERYTHING I SEE, THERE'S
A ENOUGH BLAME TO GO AROUND IN
THIS SCENARIO.
IT SEEMS LIKE NO SAFETY
PROTOCOLS WERE FOLLOWED.
THE ARMORER IS AT FAULT, FIRST
OF ALL, FOR LEAVING THEM OUT.
THEY NEVER SHOULD BE LEFT OUT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT COVID PROTOCOL
WOULD DEMAND A WEAPON BE LEFT
OUT.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
IF THAT'S THE EXCUSE BEING
GIVEN, IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE.
IT'S JUST PLAIN WRONG, AND I
THINK YES, THE A.D. HAS DEFINITE
LIABILITY BECAUSE HE PICKED A
GUN UP THAT HE DID NOT KNOW WAS
SAFE.
HE SAID IT WAS A COLD WEAPON.
HOW DID HE KNOW?
DID HE CHECK IT?
NO.
THE ARMORER SHOULD NEVER HAVE
LEFT THEIR GUNS UNATTENDED.
>> WHEN YOU AS AN ARMORER HAND A
GUN TO THE TALENT IN A MU
VALLEY, DO YOU CHECK THE
CHAMBER, FORGIVE ME IF I'M USING
THE LONG LANGUAGE, DO YOU OPEN
IT UP AND LOOK IN THE GUN AND
MAKE SURE THERE ARE NO BLANKS OR
LIVE AMMUNITION IN THERE?
>> SO THIS WAS FURNISHED BY
RENTALS NEW YORK, THIS IS AN AIR
SOFT GUN.
IT'S NOT A REAL WEAPON, BUT
WHENEVER I'M ON A SET, I MAKE
SURE THAT I HOLD IT UP FOR THE
TALENT AND ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS
TO INSPECT TO MANGE SURE THIS IS
A SAFE WEAPON.
I NEVER LOAD A WEAPON UNLESS WE
ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE FIRING
ROUNDS, ACTUALLY FIRING BLANKS,
AND ON TOP OF THAT, I ONLY PUT
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF BLANKS
IN.
IF THE SCENE CALLS FOR TWO SHOTS
TO BE FIRED, I ONLY PUT TWO
ROUNDS IN.
NOTHING MORE, AND I ANNOUNCE TO
THE CAST, I ANNOUNCE TO THE
CREW, THE WHOLE SET, LIVE WEAPON
ON SET, DISCHARGE TWO ROUNDS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE WAS NO
COMMUNICATION ON THE PART OF
THIS ARMORER TO PUT THE CREW AT
ANY EASE.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE WERE
SUPPOSEDLY ACCIDENTAL DISCHARGES
PREVIOUSLY IN THIS PRODUCTION,
THAT'S A HUGE RED FLAG, WHY
NOBODY JUMPED ON THAT.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO, AND
THIS IS ACCORDING TO "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" AND THE L.A. TIMES,
THERE WERE TWO ACCIDENTAL GUN
DISCHARGES ON THE SET IN THE
DAYS BEFORE THIS FATAL SHOOTING
THAT DID UPSET SOME CREW
MEMBERS, AND PEOPLE DID FEEL
THAT THE PROPER SAFETY PROTOCOLS
WERE NOT BEING FOLLOWED OR WERE
BEING FOLLOWED TOO LOOSELY.
I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
THAT'S A RED FLAG.
FROM ALL OF YOUR EXPERIENCE OF
DOING THIS, AND HANDLING WEAPONS
ON SET, WHAT DO YOU THINK
HAPPENED?
WHAT DO YOU THINK WENT WRONG
HERE?
>> SO I'VE ACTUALLY GOTTEN INTO
ARGUES WITH ARMORS ONLINE AND
BEEN CALLED PARANOID AND
NERVOUS, BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM
WITH THEIR PRIVATE COLLECTIONS
THEY DON'T MODIFY THE WEAPONS.
MOST YOU GET FROM A RENTAL
HOUSE, YOU CAN'T CHAMBER A
BULLET.
THIS IS A 9 MILL METER ROUND.
THIS IS A BLANK ON THE RIGHT.
THIS IS A 115 GRAIN OF HALL
POINT, YOU CAN'T LOAD THE ACTUAL
ROUND INTO MOST PROP GUNS, AND
I'VE BEEN CALLED NERVOUS AND
PARANOID BECAUSE I DID NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH ARMORISTS USING
THESE ACTUAL WEAPONS ON SET AS
OPPOSED TO THE MODIFIED WEAPONS.
LIKE I SAID, IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S JUST A COLOSSAL FAILURE
OF SAFETY PROTOCOLS AND
NEGLIGENCE AND IRRESPONSIBILITY.
LIVE AMMO, AND BLANKS SHOULD NOT
BE IN THE SAME ZIP CODE, LET
ALONE THE SAME SET.
>> LIVE AMMO, A REAL BULLET AND
A BLANK SHOULD NEVER BE ON THE
SAME SET.
>> NEVER.
THERE'S NO REASON TO EVER USE A
LIVE AMMUNITION IN ANY SET, ANY
PRODUCTION.
LOOK, IT COSTS A LITTLE MORE IF
YOU WANTED TO DO SOME KIND OF
SHOOTING SCENE, YOU WOULD HAVE
TO BRING UP SOME KIND OF GAG,
SPECIA